David is going to me to tell them that
oh yeah David is not racist David is not
racist uh shall we talk about this
earlier yeah but I said that was post
memorizing lines tonight I didn't know I
gave you a bag of Jolly Ranchers but
everything uh me guys
it's the same thing that's kind of no
it's not I gave you 50 bucks that wasn't
that much though my I'm not lying if I
give you money
really I have been checking out the
comics uh to say at least they're
they're uh they're interesting for some
reason you girls called me cute huh
usually the the reaction that I get is a
it's different than that it's a baby uh
my name is David what's your name
okay uh yeah okay hahaha
my feelings go before I even go ahead
and start anything let me go ahead and
say this leave Alexandra alone I hate a
guts but I don't want her to get hurt
physically even though I I may have
joked about it in the video but it's a
joke which leads me to the the first
comment that I want to go ahead address
comment number one David I just bought
my samurai sword when we gonna do this I
can't go to jail I'm a little [ __ ]
there I said it I said it I'm a little
[ __ ] people of my physical stature KITT
shouldn't go to jail because physically
I'm weak and I have breasts I already
know that they're gonna take me down
squeeze my breasts together make love to
me and I can't up nope nope
let's not no it's not happening copy
number two hey dog breath why don't you
come over and my cactus huh is that a
specific cactus that you have I'm not
done with that Sun I don't want to
okay Fat Boy how about you go ahead and
slaughter a cow in ten minutes then put
it on a plate then I believe that you
can actually do it damn Asians what the
and this one's the most offensive
comment of the night and I want y'all to
listen very carefully
you mother stabbed you in the neck with
them
all the way up you and the most popular
comment of all on YouTube is why are you
trying to sound black huh what does that
mean I'm done talking about this so I
actually brought an expert a lot of
comments have been saying David sounds
like a black dude as a black dude David
does not sound like a black dude exactly
hold me down son got you David sounds
more like a sassy black woman how you
gonna do me like that son
I don't something some big-ass Jordan
the Jordans look exact he is doing a
chest pass Tyree slipping ask mother
ever man bootleggers grin ah but guess
what YouTube because you requested it on
the next vlog guess who I'm gonna go
after and you guessed right it's the
girl who talked about the tsunami being
a blessing I don't remember her name but
if you guys sent me that video over
again i'ma find you
and guess what girl I'm coming after you
a lot of comments
this ain't David sounds like black as a
black dude oh you try salt like you tell
the black man i Blair I am black without
the African you're not black you will
come Africa original been proven yet
don't believe a thing anybody's been
sayin first thing I got when I co-opted
in this house was a great Capri Sun is
cuz my favorite flavor man this fool is
right as hell he tried give me cool
light now today I love you thank God
they got a million plus views then y'all
tight now that you look like Tyrese
[Music]
how huh huh
how